well the popularity of Davy Crockett the
movie in the show being so successful
they of course had to make a sequel how
the hell do you do that
you see Davy Crockett died in the last
film well this one they straight-up say
is a pure legend in that is completely
fictionalized in that there may have
been a Mike Fink him a Davy Crockett may
have crossed paths at some point but
that's where the history stops there's
no other truth in this health even
straight-up admitted in the song but
most of his chores for freedom and fun
got turned into Legends and this here is
one and as one of these totally unneeded
sequels just glorifying a myth goes it's
a lot of fun not for Davy not for his
partner Russell but for Mike fake oh my
god this guy is so enjoyable to watch he
is just the right amount of over-the-top
he's goofy he's big eyed he's always got
his mouth open he's always drinking or
smoking a cigar he's always fighting
he's always punching he's always looking
to get in trouble
you just love this guy listen to what a
loudmouth he is I am the original
ringtail roar from the thunder and
lightning country I'm a real snorter and
I had washed I can out run out jump out
sing out swim out dance out shoot out
eat out break up talk yeah I'll talk
look at his expressions nothing he does
is subtle but it's just so open you
can't stop watching him why that's
playing on civilized Piracy ain't no
question about it now make up your minds
let me know in for morning you keep me
from my drinkin he just steals every
single scene that he's in and it just
makes for a great time which is good
because the story or stories there's two
in this one are kind of lackluster also
gets drunk and accidentally challenges
Mike Fink into a boat race Mike Fink of
course agrees knowing that Davey and his
crew know absolutely nothing about doing
any boat work but through hard work
determination and their own theme song
they find the courage to actually be a
fitting match well the first half is a
the race the second half totally changes
directions
Mike Fincke and Davi become friends and
now they're on the lookout to stop some
sort of Native American scheme where
people dress up like Native Americans
and order out people and that's gonna
start a war between the white man and
them again yeah it's kind of silly but
who cares it gives a chance for Mike
Fink to be in more of the movie and I'm
totally okay with that but to the film's
credit it's not all my thinkin is gang I
mean Davy Crockett don't Davy Crockett
Russell's don't Russell they're both
really charming I don't want to while
you come across another funny character
for example there's this one guy who
sends messages and code to a bunch of
smugglers about what the boat is
carrying if a boat is carrying gold
he'll sing about a woman who has hair
just like gold and that'll be the cue to
rob it the color of Yeller Yeller yeah
this makes for a really funny scene when
he discovers that to actually Davy
Crockett might think and how he tries to
subtly alert them of what's going on I
thought maybe you fellows might like to
hear a little music
it's Crockett and think and download the
whole there's a cannon and it all builds
up to a climax with the smugglers end
it's just kind of goofy silly hokey
goofiness which I loved as a kid and I
gotta be honest still like as an adult
it's the same reason I like the original
Davy Crockett it's just totally
glorifying the myth and lore except this
time throwing in a little bit of comedy
but the comedy works so if you're
looking for a lighter version of the
Davy Crockett story maybe without the
heavier moments I'd say this is a good
one to check out nothing spectacular
just the right amount of excitement and
laughs
baby profit Tanglin
my face